[Music]
it's like I think during Co everybody
like had such a like I don't know
profound kind of introspection you know
like whatever the ones that could you
know but yeah it felt like the word
world was very very rotten then more so
now even you know it's like it's getting
more and more rotten as we you almost
look you're like that was so Earnest
back then hopeful it felt like such a
beautiful world in when yeah so anyway I
was like um I was like I want to make a
very misanthropic comedy I was like I
want to complain about us and like
starting with myself and that's why I
put myself in the movie and then I
decided to use everything around me you
know Senor AO Betto Mato my dog the
plaza the shed in La Plaza and just all
of that and then I started writing this
sort of like um mystery like crime
mystery sort of misanthropic comedy
and I was I was always going to have a
gringo that was going to be antagonizing
Señor rero but I didn't know who that
was going to be until I met Jordan and
then we did meet in that Plaza randomly
he had just hooked up with a guy that
and I had showed this guy Crystal fair
in the magic Cactus the night before
right right and then we met at the plaza
so that was all yeah so it was very
coincidental and then that night we had
dinner and we had some friends in common
and then
I like learned about his Instagram and
Jordan has a very colorful
personality and he the nicest thing he's
ever
said he loves colors that's what I say
about no but yeah I mean like he was so
open and he shared so much of his sexual
life honestly with everybody at the
table that I'm like wow uh and he asked
very difficult questions you know and
put everybody on edge and I was
fascinated and I for a week I was like
do I want to bring this person into my
life and I'm like fuck it do it for the
art and then we became really good
friends you know after all we're
neighbors now he moved next to me he's
talking me now it was it was
coincidental but uh but yeah and then
like he was very down to play himself
and make fun of himself and do all of
those like explicit sex scenes you know
and like and then that's it that's the
story so how did you feel upon receiving
this invitation to participate after the
initial meeting yeah I mean I was
surprised cuz we didn't hit it off when
we met I I feel like yeah it was normal
it was normal but I think I left being
like okay like that guy's like a little
full of himself and you left being like
that guy's annoying and like I think
that's like we were both like
understanding of that and so when you
called me I was pleasantly surprised and
I was a huge fan of Sebastian I revered
him I like you know I saw my his I saw
uh what was the first one I saw maybe
even Crystal faery was the first I saw
and then I went back but I was super
young and like very inspiring to me um
and so when he asked that I was also in
a phase of my Instagram Persona where I
was hating it I hated everyone who
followed me I was like who are you
people why are you looking at me all the
time like what do you want from me um
and so I wanted to explore that in a
different way and yeah I mean I I get
this question question a lot like how
could you let someone like take what
you've built for yourself and just like
destroy it but it didn't feel that way I
was like this is a filmmaker I trust the
the story sounds interesting I didn't
realize how mean the movie was to me
until I like the third time I saw
it what what clicked them the first time
I was like am I
fat the second time I was like does my
dick look small and the third time I was
like wait he's making fun of
me um
um but no I mean like I obviously knew
knew what it was coming for in me but I
I didn't realize how like perceptive I
guess Sebastian was being in a lot of
like he he drew out a lot of my darker
qualities and like a lot of my true
qualities which makes it a very
confusing it's a confusing project for
me but also such a rewarding one cuz I'm
like yeah those are this is me but it's
not knew I was playing up a lot of
myself but there's so much truth to you
know both of our yeah it is it was very
confusing and I was very lucky to bring
on the my co-writer Pedro Pano that I've
co-written many things with and like to
create that distance you know because I
was like the lead in the beginning you
know so it seems that I'm the lead you
know and it's like it is crazy to make a
movie about you googling yourself and
like all of this self-deprecation and
it's scary to for the product to sort of
come out as like a sort of like an ego
sort of uh unsolved sort of issue you
know and like that but then it was great
to have Pedro like being carefully like
just carefully uh building uh this
character without me overdoing the
self-deprecation which is also a sign of
like I don't know over like I don't know
over arising yourself in a way when
you're like just beating yourself up so
much that then you're like well I could
never be like that you know so also you
do die you die at the perfect time any
more of you and you would be self a
grand Isaac yeah exactly I mean like I
always knew I was going to die so that
was relieving uh you
know that was definitely relieving uh
but yeah it is a confusing project
because it is us you know and it's like
I do like San and I've read him and I've
had suicidal ideation before you know
and I made those videos and I've sucked
those cops yeah exactly so it's like a
lot of it a lot of it is real but then
it is not all that we are you know like
I'm also like a very nice uncle and like
a like reliable professional person you
know like I many things you know
Sebastian a nice Uncle reliable
professional
person yeah you know but it's like yeah
it's just like a side of you so
basically like we've repeat this so many
times but it really did Direct for
everybody was just be the worst version
of yourself you know but when because
when you are the worst version of
yourself it's so easy for one to see or
to know what are your annoying qualities
you you're very impatient or you're like
bossy or you're chap you know like you
know those things so it was just like
lean on that you know just lean on that
sure I think we have like the exact
opposite channels too it's like I know I
know to play that version I need to like
click up and you need to click down like
you you're a way less depressive person
way funnier person and I'm way more sane
and more self-aware so like you it's
just this like switch that we both had
to kind of like put on to play this this
version yeah well I mean your chemistry
is so good in the film like this I was
the third time I think I watched it was
today and like the happy clown sad clown
chemistry I mean it's like you're
playing off of each other more than I
think I realized the first couple times
I watched it um I want to know so how
much was scripted and how much was
improvised because there are these
moments like you know when you say like
you can't hurt me because I'm happy and
like there are these moments where you
know it feels like like you said you're
playing a version of yourself so had you
written all these lines for yeah I mean
like everything was written and I've
unlike what it might seem it's like most
of my movies all my movies have been
fully fully written bad Crystal faery
really but this one was no exception and
it was the process that took the longest
and like if you rewatch it it's like a
very well constructed movie and it's and
it's this long just because I usually
don't like movies that are like over 95
minutes you know and this is the first
movie that is so long that I've made and
but I couldn't cut much more because
everything is just if you cut something
then because it's a crime mystery you
know so it is a movie that requires a
lot it require a lot of scripting you
know and of course A lot of it a lot of
the words are coming from Jordan like
for instance like why when he screams
why don't you like me like that was
Jordan you know I don't think that that
was written I don't remember but also
though our scenes we workshopped a lot
in the writing process and so they ended
up in the script but like it came from
like Jordan was very involved in his
character's lines you know because he
speaks so particular you he uses like
words like what was it bji no
Ohi never heard yeah he didn't make it
but like yeah taught him Chey yeah okay
cool um where's the pitch deck for you
or me and who made it because wait that
is so true who did make that well I
chose the photo I chose the photos and I
was like just send me pictures with
celebrities I think and you sent me one
with those two women yeah there's one
with like Charlie xx and D
if they see this they're no there's
another one that is like with these two
blonde wom oh the the um what are their
name the something twins you know those
the girls Clon twins yeah claron twins
yeah I mean yeah you me that project
that pitch I mean the fact that they are
all real pictures I'm like Jesus
Christ I remember in that in that deck
in that but it's like what are you going
to do it's like you get a picture of D
le and charlex you're not going to post
it and it was a repost it was a repost
of do it's totally fine they love nobody
everyone's happy if you had if she
posted you to her grid youed you ask
everyone who wouldn't reposted if she
posted to a grid yeah Lu yeah um I one
of the things I really like about this
film is I love the way the partying is
on screen like I love that sometimes
you're looking at it and you're like I
want to be at that party and then
sometimes you're like this is grotesque
and then other times you feel like your
characters like that feeling of when
you're going to a party and you're just
like why am I here I don't want to here
just like 90% of the time yeah yeah I
mean there's just like such a good
amount of people going out and and sort
of that feeling of like I know exactly
why everybody's here this looks great
and then also like I I I don't know why
anyone's here like who is having fun
yeah going back to the grotesque aspect
of like the partying and the sex you
know like I just wanted to comment that
in this room in particular because like
it is a movie that it when it first was
shown in sentence right people loved it
and you know and the press the next day
everybody was talking about the nudity
and the sex and the dicks and some
articles where it counting how many
penises were in the movie and it is
funny and I knew of course beforehand
that if I if I put explicit sex in the
movie it was going to drive a lot of
attention you know but it is something
that is a particular aspect of one
character you know because we can't
forget that honestly the lead character
at the end of the movie Is seor AO you
know the movie ends with Senor AA you
know so it's like the sex in the movie
it's it's like a trail that Jordan is
leading it's like something that is
following Jordan not even my character
you know and like I was very
concerned that uh that uh yeah that my
Distributors would like sort of try to
um Market that aspect you know only and
we had I had to do a lot of wrestling
for that not to be the case and it it it
ended up being that you know and it was
you lost that wrestling I L I lost that
that wrestling match and it was
disappointed and in an intellectual and
artistic level to be completely honest
because yes there is a lot of dicks you
know and like usually you don't see
dicks in movies you know and it's like
why not it's like everybody watches porn
like why are we so hypocritical about
genitals it's like I think it's one of
biggest like American problem is
genitals honestly it's like genitals and
death are the most like taboo things and
it's the most common things you know and
things that we need to learn how to deal
with our sex lives and death you know
and uh so I was like yeah I'm going to
leave it you know and I'm going to keep
it and see what happens but then even
with my request it was very hard for
them to sort of present this movie as
what it is which is like a really a
social satire you know that is talking
about like social class and how
self-immersed we are and how avoidant we
become you know my character is like
suicidal idation is
avoidance overuse of social media
avoidance ketamine avoidance so it was
so much more about that than the dicks
and the sex you know and like I have
like now a personal sort of fight that
against like those sort of like terms
for a movie you know gay movie Black
movie it's like I'm over that and I find
it very patronizing and like uh very
dangerous really not dangerous like I
don't know but I think you have you have
like tangible proof now that it isn't it
isn't just like these systems that have
done it cuz the the it worked it's like
the the audience a lot of them came cuz
they thought they were going to see 30
dicks and I think the joke is on the
audience when they come to the movie and
it's so much more than that but like
they're that worked for a lot of people
and like audiences are really shallow
and they need to like they need
something to grab on to which is why I
actually was the opposite I fought for
the dicks in the marketing cuz I'm like
I know these fucking idiots are going to
come if they think that there's real sex
and 30 Whatever Gets people yeah and
it's like then and then there's the joke
of like yeah they come and see this like
scathing class satire and like and ail
San they're getting introduced to a
million new things but I think like to
to me it's the the disappointment and I
I feel the same but it's not just like
the distributors in the business but
it's the audience yeah it is true the
the problem was that because like it
feels like or at least what I was
getting in social media I know a lot of
people have seen this movie and people
that I really admire too directors but I
think that they really did Target a gay
audience you know and like it got a huge
gay audience you know and like I would
say 80% of the feedback that I've gotten
on my social media is from gay people
and it's totally fine you know but it
was not it was not made to be that you
know and it's not a gay movie to me
despite the fact that I'm gay and
Jordan's gay and there's gay sex but
it's like like a straight movie with
straight people in it having straight
sex is never categorized as a straight
movie you know so it's like not because
we're less that's what we get and we
made a gay movie and it's like it is
problematic you know because it does get
to wise your art you know and it makes
it very Niche when it's like the the
exist sort of problems that this movie
is dealing with are very uh fundamental
to any living creature you know yeah
which is like just like the State of
Affairs now of the world is really sad
and very rotten and like we don't know
how to go about it you know but but yeah
that's like only I just wanted to make
that comment you know but it's like it's
still it's like I love the dicks in the
movie and it's like it's a sexy funny
movie you know but yeah but I mean sadly
I think that really sadly I think that
you know with movies a lot of the time
when we're trying to mark it from this
entertainment perspective it's like we
think or some people think you know like
well dicks equals fun and social satire
doesn't equal fun to get people in seats
and I think I mean that's a whole other
problem but yeah yeah totally I
appreciate what you're saying there was
something about like also being just not
to go on this tangent so long there's
more question but there was something
about like also gay men you know because
like I don't know if you remember blue
is the war war scholar you know a lot of
vagina a lot of vagina way more vagina
in that movie than Dix in this one and
it was never advertised that people knew
there's a lot of di in this yeah I know
but there was like but what I'm saying
is like there was like there was a lot
of
eroticism in that movie and like it felt
like the sort of lesbian sex was very
important to that director because the
very
artistic yeah because they were very s
long sustained SC very explicit here the
sex is a joke honestly it's like the
dicks are there but it's like the guy
finds the phone the phone of Sebastian
you know so it's like the sex is sort of
like a background comedic element we
always thought it was funny like we
never thought we were being like Chloe
7e Brown bunny like looking up like
artistic moment like we always were like
this is like we the bigger dick the
better shove it down my throat let me
find the phone like it was always played
as like a prop like a comedic prop sure
yeah but that guy the guy who says why
are you judging me the guy who like gets
who like kind of hits on you and then
gets mad at your response I actually
think that's kind of a great foil to
what we're talking about like his whole
Persona and reaction in that moment is
very striking I think because I mean
because it's in the movie like you know
that you don't keep in every interaction
a person would have on a nude beach
where everybody's trying to get laid
like but that that moment with him where
he's like don't you judge me cuz you're
fucking miserable like I really love
that whole moment and I feel like it
kind of needles the for sure that is
that is I that's I like that you see it
that way but that is such a real gay
moment like where like you just you just
simply say no to someone and they take
it to that level that's what you were
trying like right cuz they're just like
you you're doing this cuz you like
you're judging me it's like no I just
don't want to suck your dick like it's
very no he's like but you looked at
it it's there yeah I love all the
moments where you um like I also think
that all the dicks are we're seeing them
through your eyes which is you being
like I'm really depressed and I came to
this beach to have fun but I'm just
being like dicks dicks dicks dicks and I
love they're actually all like an inch
bigger but you see them through the his
eyes and so
they're well I I noticed this time I was
watching it that when Senor Vero sees
Jordan's um like the guy that he slept
with that night she has that same like
like when she sees his chest or
something there's something about the
fleshiness yeah that she's like she's
never seen a bear I remember Catalina
when we shot that scene she was like I'm
never watching this disgusting movie
really yeah he's like why is he licking
his asshole I'm like oh cuz he was
that's something people do in
bad yeah what was her reaction
overall she loves it yeah she loves it
and uh We've collaborated a lot we we
did the maid and then before that we did
a movie called life skills me and then
another one called old cats like we work
a lot but we hadn't worked in a while I
don't think she was excited that I asked
her to be a maid again she was like come
on but well she got to do an a Mexican
accent which is like for Spanish
speaking audiences is pretty fucking
impressive honestly like is she Chilean
yeah she's Chilean and she pull it off
incredible like Mexicans couldn't tell
you know so it's
like like on top of how of of a great
performance she gives like comedic and
also very heartfelt she's doing an
accent you know like flawlessly yeah
those are her highest like drama like
it's like her most that she had to like
be in the moment like having yeah having
to do yeah yeah well I love the scene
with her at the Kera I thought that was
so it's fun because it's actually one of
the only scenes in the movie where we
feel like we're like okay we're in
Mexico City with people who live there
and they're at a family gathering and
she gets off the zoi milco like bat and
I really like that whole uh scene and I
wonder it made me think about like I
wonder how audiences in Mexico City have
felt about this because there's so many
little references somebody call it the
best the best Mexican movie in 15 years
I'm like it's not Mexican yeah like
people really liked it yeah it was very
very well received and I think that you
know how people go to another country
and they can sort of like pinpoint the
the floss or like the sort of Inn Cy of
that culture just because of being an
outsider and I think that's what
happened here you know like how Mato
treats seor AA you know or how like yeah
like that sort of like cast system that
Mexicans have it's pretty crazy when
you're there and you witness that it's
really because in Chile I grew up with
mates myself but in differently than in
Mexico like people feel very guilty
about it it's like there is more of a
guilt like a F of like having employees
or you know like being served there's
like in Mexico it's very like I pay you
you do it you know and he's very
interested in that sort of like in the
culture and uh I think that resonated a
lot for Mexican audiences yeah it was
like the Mexico was like the second
screening we had after Sundance and like
Sundance was like laugh laugh laugh
laugh laugh and Mexico was like it was a
kind of grave feeling but then the
reaction of people after people were so
felt so seen and they were very moved by
it even if they weren't they didn't see
it as much as a comedy at that screen
but like they felt it so much deeper
than the American audience that can kind
of just be like oh like ha like yeah
like we go to Mexico and ruin it well
yeah yeah yeah um I wonder how each of
you have felt um about how this movie
maybe Chang how you think about yourself
a little bit because I mean obviously
you both engage with uh imagery and
visuals of yourselves in different ways
all the time but did this movie change
how you think about your song I I
thought it had you know in the beginning
I'm like I'm a new person and then like
two months later I'm reading San like
I'm Googling fent of AR no not so much
but yeah it did it did have an effect
and it's hard to tell you know like uh
personal growth it's like It's Tricky
you know because it's never immediate
you know like usually like you do a
therapy or you have like I don't know
like a very strong psychedelic
experience and then you learn things
that don't come immediately it can take
years for it sort of that blog to create
a a like visible difference in in in the
way that you perceive yourself but I do
believe that yes in this case to have
sort of made fun of that obnoxious sort
of like
ungrateful a you know like wimy like I
don't know Bourgeois artist instead of
being so grateful you know about like
not being fucking bummed or like fear of
like being raped or killed like honestly
like that's what we should be grateful
about these days you know so it's like
it really did remove me from that you
know and it's like I feel that when that
those aspects of myself come back I'm
way more self-aware you know and like I
I'm able to dismiss them a little
quicker you know just because I already
made fun of that guy even killed him you
know so yeah in my case for sure but the
rotting doesn't go away cuz then it's
like you know in the we're talking about
how movie didn't Market it right so it's
like that's rotting yeah yeah yeah and
it's like that's it's the same kind of
issues that we are making fun of which I
think like to to a lot of to some people
seeing the movie like that how close it
is is hard to stomach for some people
that you can be you can observe it and
be in it and that be your real life at
the same time and you could be you could
be making fun of yourself and it's still
being your real experience and like it
doesn't
change that much but to know a little
bit more but it is crazy because like
you assume that it should be somehow
paralyzing you know that you're like
wait I am this rotting privileged person
complaining about things that people
would die to have like Health you know
and and then you still sort of move on
with your sort of Superfluous
personality or like your sort of like um
yeah it is really crazy the Paradox is
insane and I think it's like the the
sort of like U cross that privileged
people carry in a way where it's like
you are of course you are allowed to
suffer and you do suffer you know but
the suffering that you have in
comparison it's so it's so minimal you
know but it is real you know uh it's a
different kind it's an existential kind
of suffering don't talk about Israel
hey he said but it is real so do you
guys catch that joke is real um anyway I
really loved uh the I mean I really
appreciated the you showing all of the
the depression suicidal thoughts and
being able to laugh at it I mean I feel
like most people who have struggled with
depression like want to be able to laugh
with their friend about how shitty they
felt at some point hopefully and so I
wonder like if you have uh heard
anything like people's reactions to yeah
know that was amazing and I just got the
Goosebumps look get in the
camera yeah look you see that no it's
because like uh a lot of people have
told me that they've also had suicidal
idation and it's like it seems that it's
very normal it's very normal and it's
like and that's why soran is quoted in
the movie so much because it is an
intellectual exercise to imagine your
death or imagine of finishing your life
it has nothing to do with being
psychotic or a very unwell person it's
actually a sign of health and
intelligence yeah and you think of
Health you know M this sort of like
spiritual teacher had this saying that
to be well adjusted to like a sick
Society is not a sign of wellbeing you
know that you are like fully happy in a
world as we know it is insane it seems I
mean it means that you're not looking
around and that you are incapable of
suffering the pain of others or putting
yourself in their shoes you know and
it's like even enjoying your
privileges it's a little hard when you
know that so many people are in the dark
hungry you know and like dying so it's
like um I a lot of people came forward
and like I think that it's a movie that
open up the talk of suicide which is
like the intellectual sort of approach
to Suicide it's very important and it's
very important to know that you are
alive because you want to be alive and
not because you are meant to last you
know you were not fruit you know it's
like we're people with wills and we
could end it if you're really in pain so
it's like think about it and keep alive
wanting to be alive not because you're
here and then I don't know like
Catholics told you that life is worth it
just because it is you know like
pro-life people it's like it's not life
is not worth it just because it's lives
some lives are terrible sure and the and
the shame of ever feeling suicidal
doesn't help that whole run is really
right if it was a bigger audience I
think there would have been I think
you're right
should we get let's give a little
Applause okay thank you all right last
question um could each of you tell me
something you learned from the other
person okay you go
first
ooh yeah I mean it's
it's it's I I've said this before but
like I think I think everyone should
have a movie written about their
personality by someone who hates them
them
um I think everyone should have to go
through that but yeah I think I think
Sebastian helped me see sides of myself
that I was definitely blind to I think
there's like a maybe a toxic positivity
to my character or myself that like when
you ask the last question I'm like it's
something that I that has changed me in
the movie when I find myself going into
that like you you know you manifest
things and I'm like I know it's kind of
true but then is it also not true it's
like I I still believe a lot of the
principles of my character but it also
it's a completely selfish mindset
because it negates everything around you
but you and I do believe you can make
fucking miracles happen when you target
whatever you want but you are ignoring
everything else around you so I think
like even my character's kind of Arc is
realized in that he is not the center of
this story not the center of this
universe not the center of any of this
and so like you know then he leaves at
the end but I don't know I think I think
yeah in general I I always wanted to
tell my story in my way and I think SE
seeing myself and my story through
Sebastian's eyes um just made me made me
look at myself and a deeper way and like
a less positive way and I've I can't lie
like it's it's I've been so insecure at
times from the this the release of this
movie CU people see me and they're like
see the movie and they're like that's
you now and I'm like I know it's not I
know there's like layers and
complications but I don't know I think
the biggest thing I learned is just like
learning you know like the feeling of
learn like you're like I know I'm
learning something from this I'm not
exactly sure what it is but like I've
felt so much growth through this process
and just even like the experience of
knowing Sebastian and our relationship
and how it's grown cuz like we really
have like like learn to to love each
other and know each other a lot better
and like day to day it's still like not
perfect and we we struggle but yeah I
mean I yeah I I I think like
yeah what seeing seeing myself through
through a very very precise eye I've
I've learned a lot
from youo now I didn't know that it
wasn't I learned how to sh
online no I really like uh honestly like
I got to be honest you know when I first
met Jordan I was very judgmental you
know because his Instagram it is crazy
you know like or you mean like there
were so many funny things but there were
also like really crazy photo shoots
where he's like half naked like with
bruises and looking sexy and then you're
like what is he doing like I'm like this
is the last thing I would ever do in my
life you know so it's like we were so
opposite and I was like very judgmental
you know and it's like I but I think
that unlike Jordan's perception that
people watch the movie and they're like
that's Jordan I feel that on the
contrary because like honestly like the
quality of knowing how to laugh at
yourself but then continue to be
yourself it's an amazing quality because
it's very paradoxical but it's also very
real you know and it means that you've
come to decide that you are this person
or you want to be this person and you
know what that person is for you and for
the other for other people you know it's
like Jordan is very far from being of
believe yous to how he come across you
know and like that to me was like a huge
surprise in a way you know but it was
very it was revealed very quickly you
know it's like it was revealed in the
phone call that I'm like I want to make
fun of you and you're like yeah okay
keep going and then I was like I don't
want to be ironic I really want to
destroy what you do and like he was
laughing hysterically and and we
immediately wear in the same page you
know so it's like I think that yeah I
think I've learned with Jordan like not
to be judgmental and not only for for
our connection you know or how how we
or my sort of prejudices of him you know
but it's really how he goes about people
and like I feel that uh Jordan being so
open about his sexual life for instance
you know it's something it's terrifying
you know but at the same time is so
healthy you know and like it could be
seen as unhealthy you know because it
feels like sex for a lot of people is
evil you know or like something that is
should be secretive secretive or or
hidden you know but then really sex is
so infantile in the way that it's
portraying this movie in a way I mean
the way that Jordan Sher said you know
it's like it's just infantile the way I
do sex
totally he loves farting he loves fart
sex they burp me at the end know you
know what I'm saying it's like it is
just like having fun it's like that's
what it is it's very playful you know
like especially like group sex is so
playful it's not there's nothing
there's nothing evil about it or or dark
or seed it's really it's literally a
play pan it's like twister it's twist
there's walls there's toys there's
slings there's
swings so yeah I think that just like
really like watch out with my prejudices
you know and like just be more like open
awesome thank you for that question we
never gotten that but I think that was
healing for us yeah we're like almost I
charge group therapy Rings normally but
um well uh we should wrap but thank you
so much for
[Music]
for